hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and in this video i'm going to talk a
little bit more about um order flow
inverse imbalances now you know over the
weekend i did a training on
inverse imbalances as well as value
areas and you know i want to talk about
inverse balances today this is um april
7th 2022 because you know today there
were quite a few in several markets um
early on now
if you're
not familiar with what an inverse
imbalance is first i'll start start with
what a
imbalance is in the in a footprint chart
in a footprint chart
in the two-way auction when you have
more aggressive traders on one side by a
ratio of usually four to one again you
could change it to whatever ratio you
like but most traders use four to one
now when you have
three or more
imbalances in a bar
that are
coming sequentially you know one right
after the other so basically neatly
stacked on top of each other that would
be called a stacked imbalance now
with stacked imbalances you have bullish
ones you have bearish ones now a
stacked by imbalance would be you know
an up candle a green candle
with
three binding balances or more that are
stacked neatly on top of each other at
each level
the stack selling and balance would be
three or more selling imbalances stack
neatly on top of each other in the down
candle now an inverse imbalance is a
stacked imbalance but with a bit of a
twist
so a bullish inverse imbalance would be
a stacked selling a balance in an up bar
because normally you would expect to see
a stack selling a balance in a down bar
and a bearish inverse imbalance would be
a stacked by an imbalance in a down bar
again normally you would expect to see a
stacked buying imbalance in an up bar
right because you know aggressive buyers
are lifting the offers and taking the
market higher however when you see an
inverse imbalance it is generally a sign
of
traders that are getting trapped in the
market right they're aggressive traders
that are selling into strong
passive bids or buying from strong
passive offers so let's take a look at
the charts today
so this is uh the mes the micro e minis
and at this low here the low of the day
at this time i believe we did make lower
lows
coming down into uh 44 52 and a half
right you see this nice stacked
selling imbalance okay the market was
coming down right it had dropped made
new lows boom aggressive sellers came in
here this is probably most likely a stop
that just got triggered down here at 53
and then the market snapped back
and rallied up now
technically we would consider
these
sellers the people that sold into this
low here um you know trapped but again
it's not an overwhelming amount of
trapped traders you know you're talking
70 28. so that's 146.
you know about 100 and you know close to
175 contracts so there's plenty of time
for them to get out up here it's not
like this
this little amount of
trapped traders is going to cause this
you know 10-point rally you know there's
plenty of time for 70
175 contracts to be covered you know
anywhere in here but really what you're
looking for is
a sign that you know this low or you
know if i'll show you later a stacked um
a bearish
inversion balance which means you know
the aggressive traders were caught
offsides
but what what it's indicative is is a
market that's snapping you know it has a
quick move down and snaps back right
means these prices down here are
rejected and the market immediately
comes back and you could write it on the
way back up right and there's a nice
move um you know next bar obviously up
and then you got that little further
push up here as well back up to uh up to
70.
and
let me see it not sure if there was one
earlier
in this day
but
yesterday
uh
wednesday i believe there was one let me
just scroll back here right this is
this one happened you know right after
the cash closed and you'll notice
you know it was just this little snap up
here market snapback then went sideways
cash closed you'll notice how the market
came right back up to those levels that
it rejected right these are areas let me
put this crosshairs up here
you know this area got rejected pretty
quick
the market came off market came back up
this area of rejection
and what happens right you rejected it
earlier it's rejecting it again sold off
going into this futures closed and the
futures reopened
quickly quick move down to 70 and a
quarter rejected these lower prices and
again started trading higher right this
is uh what
71 and a quarter you'll notice we came
down to 74.
we didn't really come down into it till
much later and take it out so you know
that was another sign of rejection let
me see if there was any more during the
regular session
well there was this one right off the
cache open uh sorry
the not cache open the fomc right the
knee jerk reaction up knee jerk reaction
down
and
market went back up right eventually it
did come back down but again doesn't
look like much of a move
again you're probably not going to be
trading fomc announcement but you got
the rejection early on
rejection a minute later and the market
continued in that direction a little
further up
before
you know subsiding back down now
let's take a look at another market um
look at nasdaq
or
well take a look at
mini russell
just give it a second here to come up
there's a mini russell here
today in mini russell
all right we have this move up
up here
you've got an inverse imbalance this is
a bearish one how do i know it's bearish
well it's the red candle you got those
bind stack binding balances now we have
this coded into the order flows trader
software all right so that you'll you'll
see where
the
bearish inverse imbalances are and the
bullish inverse imbalances are
so that you can re just very quickly
just see it on the chart oh yeah there i
have it rather than oh you know i got to
analyze look closer at the chart and see
that
um you see that and so there's your
inverse imbalance just prints right up
there you can't miss it it's sort of
like you know a lighthouse shining a
light and the market you know sold off
down into new lows um
how about mini dao ym
this morning
again today is uh april 7th
see if there's anything in here
okay
here about 950 right we hit those new
lows start going sideways let me just
open this chart up a little bit more
you know we're going sideways market
pushes down
rejects these lower prices again because
you know our low for the day is at 34
000 93 and you're just
trying to keep testing these lows here
right you came down
and this bar got all the way down to 97
so is that four ticks off the low and
then just keeps going sideways and then
you get that last push down
and then it just snaps back really quick
and you know puts in this nice rally up
now you know question people will ask
well how do you trade these well if you
have this
you see this as qui as soon as it forms
right you don't have to wait for the bar
to close to see it form because you're
seeing this in real time
you know how you trade it is you just
wait for this bar to close
or you know it's going to be you know
already the high is you know 120. you
just drop in a buy stop 122 123 right up
in here let the market take you in if
this market starts to go sideways
and doesn't go any higher
then you're not going to get into the
trade right if you don't want to just oh
you know i got
inverse and balance here a bullish
inverse and balance i just immediately
get long you know because there's going
to be times where the next bar just sort
of goes inside and just sort of goes
sideways and falls down right you want
to let the market take you into the
trade i like to you know set my entry
you know a couple of ticks above the
high of the bar
before along with the um
inverse and balance so you've got the
inverse and balance showing right here
so i'll just drop in a buy stop just
right in here you know i'm ready to go i
don't have to necessarily wait i can see
as we're making these highs i can just
be ready with a stop already up here at
23 and just move it down as we start
getting closer to the close of the bar
just as you would um you know for that
cell
um in the mini dowel or sorry in the
russell that was the mini dial i was
just talking about
let's go back here right so
okay i know i got my stacked inverse and
balance you know and again this is a one
minute chart you can you can find
inverse and balances on uh tick based
charts you know whether you use like a
100 tick chart or a 50 tick chart or a
200 tick chart if you're into fibs you
know 233 tick chart um a volume based
chart a range based chart
if there's an inversion balance it will
appear you know so i would just be
what ready to drop in my cell stop right
in here around 90 and
um you know the low of this bar is what
91.1
you know just dropping a cell stop you
know 90.9 90.8 now it did pull back a
bit up right but didn't get back up to
that inverse and balance where it
rejected those prices and then just sort
of went sideways before it fell over and
had a nice you know move down and and
further
so again you know look for those inverse
imbalances you know whatever market
you're trading they sometimes you know
you might not get one for a day and then
the next day you get two or three it
really
it just varies on market conditions so
if you like this video and you want to
see more videos like this be sure to
subscribe hit the like button but you
know make sure you subscribe so you'll
be
notified when i post new videos i'm
trying to be more proactive and posting
more videos just to get this education
out there for everybody so
have a great day everybody and bye bye